senator from the get-go you
questioned whether or not covid could
have originated
at that lab you were roundly mocked a
lot of republicans
joined you they were mocked you know the
social media companies
shut it down yesterday jake sullivan
who's the president's national security
adviser was talking over on one of the
other channels
about uh how we will get to the origins
and it's it's not very optimistic
about how the government is going to
leverage the assets of the federal
government to get
china to give us the truth here's jake
sullivan listen to this
what joe biden did in europe this week
was rally the democratic world to speak
with a common voice on this issue for
the first time
since covid broke out president trump
wasn't able to do it president biden was
and it is that diplomatic spade work
rallying the nations of the world
imposing political and diplomatic
pressure on china
that is a core part of the effort we are
undertaking
to ultimately face china with the stark
choice either they will allow
in a responsible way investigators in to
do the real work of figuring out where
this came from or
they will face isolation in the
international community
how terrified is china right now senator
because if they don't cough up the
information we will isolate them
internationally i don't think xi jinping
is quaking in his boots that
joe biden's not going to invite him to
coffee at the next g20 look it's not
surprising
that this crew doesn't traffic in
threats with their enemies the only
people they seem to threaten are allies
like israel but nor should it require
china's cooperation first off china is
not going to cooperate they're not going
to open those labs and let american
scientists and researchers go in
and second there's more than enough
evidence to hold china accountable now
as you said from the very beginning
i noted that this virus very well could
have originated in those labs i mean
it didn't come from a remote mountain
village next to a cave full of bats
it came from a city larger than new york
just a few blocks down the street from
the lab
where they researched these viruses a
lab that's run by a woman literally
nicknamed
the bat lady it's well past time the
biden administration began imposing
consequences on china
like pulling their most favored nation
trading status or pulling all the visas
that chinese communist party officials
and their kids get to come to this
country every year
we can do a lot told china accountable
and we're not doing nearly enough
stop giving money for gain of function
research to countries like that
how vindicated did you feel when the
left started talking about the
lab leak theory and you could finally
write about it on social media without
being blocked
well honestly i gotta say i wish i'd
been wrong from the very beginning
about this virus and all of its effects
around the world and here at home
um you know i wish i'd looked back and
been called an alarmist
but i wasn't unfortunately and i think
it's a reminder
that we shouldn't allow companies like
facebook and twitter to control the
terms of our discourse
we might have gotten to the truth a lot
faster if we had an open honest
discussion
and not censorship from big tech
companies so i want you i want you to
hear what dr fauci said yesterday the
second time he's really responding to
criticism after
walking on water for the first 13 months
of this virus
not here but other places listen
it is essential as a scientist
that you evolve your opinion and your
recommendations
based on the data as it evolves
and that's the reason why i say people
who then criticize me about that
are actually criticizing science here we
go again
uh why don't you take this from here
yeah tony thaucy is not acting as a
scientist or a doctor anymore he's
acting as a democratic party activist in
a white lab code
why doesn't he tell us what science what
data
backs up the biden administration's
stupid mask mandate for airports and air
airplanes i mean are you more likely to
get the coronavirus in an airport than
you're a shopping mall
or an airplane with its massive
filtration systems is it really
necessary to kick off a family with an
autistic child who can't wear a mask
peacefully for an entire airplane does
dr fouch have evidence to support that
from
the data and the science i mean we
shouldn't allow
tony fauci and facebook to determine
what we can and cannot say
about this virus because from the
beginning he's been giving politicized
advice he's admitted
that he's changed his advice based on or
what would be herd immunity levels not
based on what he thinks he sees in the
data but what he thinks the american
people are ready to hear
why doesn't he just tell us what the
facts are he does have power
and he has international standing can
you imagine if he used that power to say
i don't know what this virus is china is
not giving me answers
i can't prepare the cdc or recommend
them for a test that's going to hit our
shores
i don't know about the mutation because
they're not being transparent
with all that pressure that would have
helped solve the problem
that would have humanized him more i'm
an elite
virologist i have this international
standing and i am not getting answers
that would have helped instead he subtly
took his points
his talking points from the left and
took most of his
stature to go at trump
yeah there's no doubt about that in fact
he seemed from the very beginning to be
more concerned about protecting his own
agency's reputation and his reputation
and his friends in the science world
around or in the around the world
to include the scientist in this very
lab in wuhan which is agency indirectly
funded with hundreds of thousands of
taxpayer dollars
so he's more cons concerned with co cya
than he was about being
open and honest about what china was up
to and what we didn't know
because of china's deceitfulness